well first off Lynne when I first saw
you guys announced this I thought who
had the foresight to shoot this back in
2016 because when do you guys announce
that I thought if they'd only have done
that with wicked with the Dean and
Kristen that would solve all that movies
probably yeah who had the foresight to
shoot this four years ago oh I was lucky
enough to see a demon Kristen in that
first year
weirdly wicked is is really foundational
on how I write because the only person
we knew in show business was our
collaborator Alec slack more when we
were working on in the heights so I sat
in the pit at wicked a bunch and learned
how an orchestra works by watching him
conduct but in terms of our show I think
that um a couple of things happened
Hamilton opened at the public
off-broadway and we realized really
quickly we have the thing you cannot
bobble or pay for which is everyone who
left the show told everyone they knew
about and that continued on Broadway and
so access to the show was always tricky
because you can only serve the meal
1,300 people at a time on Broadway so we
prioritize two things one we felt it
would be a crime if history teachers
couldn't bring their kids to the show
and so we created the edge' ham
initiative and over the past five years
250,000 students have seen Hamilton for
10 bucks each because of that initiative
and two we realized this company that
was performing the show in its first
year was really special and we were in
the position to prioritize we gotta get
him we don't know what we're gonna do
with the footage but we should get it
while we're all here in the same
building and it took us the better part
of a year we actually filmed the first
performance four years ago to this day
and I'm so grateful we did and we we
independently financed it and we filmed
a Sunday night show film is Sunday
matinee filmed all night Sunday all day
Monday on our day off then filmed all
day Tuesday and filmed a live Tuesday
night's show and so it was a three-day
indie film shoot while we continued to
do eight shows a week um so
I look pretty sleepy in this movie and
luckily that I also have a newborn child
have that's fine but I'm so grateful we
got it because in this moment when
there's no theatre we have this gift for
the world and it's it's it's the show
itself yeah what surprised you about
seeing it in movie form what surprised
me countless little moments because
obviously I have my very specific
bandaged point from inside the show so I
always watch the movie with a bit of
double vision I'm watching details from
this incredible ensemble I've never
noticed before and I'm also remembering
oh here's where I'm making Rene laughs
Stage Left
because we have five seconds before we
go back on stage like I'm remembering my
backstage traffic as I'm watching
Tommy's incredible onstage film right I
know you said that your kids don't
really sing Hamilton songs but they're
obsessed with your welcome from Ilana
and Dwayne's been posting videos like he
sings that to his daughter all the time
what do you think is like the appealing
factor or the lasting appeal of that
song well it's a nice backwards way of
teaching kids manners to be honest if
ever my I give my kids food or a drink
and they don't say thank you I go you're
welcome
and passive-aggressively I'm they go and
thank you so you know it's as a
etiquette primer it actually just works
really nicely because that's something
that all kids sort of you try to teach
your kids and we've got a song that you
can now sing it yeah that's true now in
terms of releasing us now I mean it
seems kismet that it would be coming out
right now but what do you think the
significance is of this coming up now in
the middle of this black lives matter
movement well what's what's wild to me
about the show because it deals in the
origins and the contradictions of the
origins of this country is that not a
word has changed since 2015 but the
world has changed since 2015 and
different things resonate in different
ways depending on where we are as a
country and where we are in the world
when the show first came out everyone
was talking to how
embodied hope because of the Obama era
when Trump won the line immigrants we
get the job done went from a laugh line
an applause line to this like defiant
like yes and right now young black and
brown leaders are creating an overdue
conversation in this country about
systemic racism that is at the roots of
our founding that is in the original sin
of slavery and finding that the lyrics
of revolution in the show are resonating
in this moment I find really interesting
and and and humbling to be honest
because that notion of we reckon with
the the flaws and contradictions of our
country and we are we're we're deciding
what we stand for and what we won't
stand for and you know I think the show
resonates in that way now well very well
said yeah I'll just say as we wrap up
I've been listening to soundtrack for
four years so I'm very excited to
finally see you guys in the flesh do
this the actual physicality thank you
very much letting great to talk to you
thanks